[Music]
on this tuesday night the toll of
russia's war in ukraine why the u.n
believes more civilians have died than
what's been officially reported we are
working to corroborate every single
incident
and a warm welcome for ukrainians in
newfoundland and labrador
oil companies making record profits the
pressure to invest it in clean energy
critics call the federal environmental
impact law pipeline killer now alberta's
top court says it's unconstitutional and
the art of smashing records it's the
highest price ever paid the staggering
sale of this work by andy warhol
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is a warning tonight the extent of
the death toll in ukraine is likely to
be far higher than what's been reported
the head of the un human rights
monitoring mission says thousands more
civilians have died than are accounted
for in the official figure of thirty
four hundred exact numbers are
impossible to gather right now because
some areas such as the bombarded city of
mariupl can't be accessed as well the
world health organization says the
conflict's impact on ukraine's health
care system has led to 3 000 preventable
deaths
russian troops have suffered big
setbacks too but the american director
of national intelligence said today the
u.s believes russia's president is in
this for the long haul
but putin most likely also judges that
russia has a greater ability and
willingness to endure challenges
than his adversaries and he is probably
counting on u.s and eu resolve to weaken
as food shortages inflation energy
prices get worse
after more than 10 weeks it's becoming a
terrible endurance test for the
ukrainian people redmond shannon has our
top story tonight
germany's foreign minister reopens the
country's embassy in kiev the latest
nation to do so returning some sense of
normalcy to ukraine's capital
but elsewhere in the country the war
rages more airstrikes in the port city
of odessa killing one person and as
ukraine claims to have retaken some
villages in harkee region officials
there say 44 bodies have been found in
the ruins of a building destroyed back
in march
the united nations official number for
civilian deaths is almost 3 400 but they
added a troubling caveat tuesday all i
can say for now is that that it is
thousands higher than than the numbers
that we have currently given to you the
big uh
black hole is really marieuple where
it's been difficult for us to fully
access and to get uh
fully corroborated information the mayor
of mariupol has said as many as 20 000
civilians may have died there after
russian attacks obliterated much of the
city ukrainian troops still inside the
besieged as of style steelworks claim
100 civilians remain with them that
after it was thought the last of the
civilians were evacuated over the
weekend any who were ill may face
further struggles with a warning tuesday
about the war's impact on health care 40
of households have at least one member
in need of chronic treatment
that they can no longer find
resulting in an estimated at least 3 000
premature avoidable deaths
from health to food another call from
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
for the world to help with its grain
exports it's sitting on 8 billion euros
worth of wheat right now from last
year's harvest they cannot export it
they have no access to the sea during
his visit to ukraine sunday prime
minister justin trudeau said canada
would help find solutions it doesn't
serve anyone if vladimir's putin's war
is not just killing ukrainians but is
starving people around the world with
ports out of action and train lines a
frequent target it will be far from easy
redmond shannon global news london
ukraine's population is 44 million
people almost 6 million of those people
have now fled the country it is
according to the un the fastest growing
refugee crisis since the second world
war most people are staying in nearby
countries romania poland moldova hungary
and slovakia poland which has taken in
more than three million ukrainians most
of those who have left are elders when
women and children most men under the
age of 60 have been prohibited from
leaving so they can join the fight
tens of thousands of ukrainians have
also applied to come to canada
newfoundland and labrador vowed back in
march to offer safe haven to some of
them and the first government-sponsored
plane load of displaced ukrainians
arrived last night as ross lord reports
the premier says hosting them is an
honor
in a province that takes pride in
putting strangers at ease this plane
load of new arrivals lands right in
newfoundland and labrador's comfort zone
premier andrew fury greeting the first
of 166 passengers angelica as onlookers
send their own messages of support
after fleeing the devastating russian
invasion coming to a canadian province
whose rugged beauty helps offset its
tenuous finances is a huge relief stan
has a job in favor welcome stan who's
headed to bay chamber
stan is a mining engineer he says his
father is still in central ukraine but
urged him to leave but
i very worried about my father he's
nominal and
he will just told me that
as i'm in this war you have your chance
for your future this first of its kind
airlift cost an estimated 350 000
including on the ground logistics it's a
reward on another investment almost two
months ago when the province opened an
office in poland to help ukrainians
relocate
sorting out things like travel documents
and transportation plans as other
provinces ramp up their support the
federal government is promising to move
ahead with its own plans for targeted
charter flights the feds say they've
received more than 204 000 applications
from ukrainians approving more than 91
000 and that more than 24 000 have
arrived in canada since january first
arriving ukrainians have been granted an
emergency travel visa that allows them
to live and work in canada for three
years
and the newfoundland and labrador
government says they'll get provincial
medicare and prescription drug coverage
other challenges could take time like
nurturing this seven-year-old girl who
doesn't speak english
with hundreds of other ukrainians
applying to fly here these arrivals
might be only the beginning of this
small province's big relief effort ross
lord global news
as fighting rages in ukraine oil and gas
prices have been shooting up in part
because of the uncertainty about
supplies from russia anyone filling up
their tank knows this canadian gas
prices have hit record highs the average
price of a liter is 1.92 cents now it's
well over two dollars in some places and
who is making record profits from it oil
companies shell made 9.1 billion in the
last quarter nearly triple the amount
from the same period last year chevron
6.3 billion quadruple last year's
profits exxon 5.5 billion canadian
companies are swimming in profit too
suncor made 2.95 billion dollars in the
first quarter more than triple the
amount from the same time last year and
enbridge imperial oil synovus and
canadian natural resources all made big
profits in early 2022.
oil companies are now facing pressure
over what to do with the windfall
heather eurix west looks at canada's
push to put that money to good use
in a province known for beef and oil
surging energy prices are a provincial
coffer cash cow but alberta's premier is
frustrated we're concerned that
these
very
strong commodity prices and big profits
are not turning into jobs albertans
rightly expect to see
real economic benefit particularly when
prices and profits are this high after
several difficult years for the industry
oil companies are reluctant to invest
they're going back to shareholders and
they're going to buy backs and that's
what a company does is it makes money
and then it you know sends it back to
the shareholders what we have seen and
heard so far
from many of those same energy companies
is that the investor community is saying
don't don't increase your production
here and that's an issue as the world
faces two big problems when it comes to
fossil fuels on one hand there is a
global oil shortage and prices will only
rise until there is more supply
but the climate crisis looms heavily as
well and the federal environment
minister says oil companies need to pull
their weight we think that these
companies with making record level
profit should invest as well in
in this decarbonization the oil and gas
sector is canada's biggest polluter and
if its largest producers are to reach
their net zero by 2050 commitments huge
investments in carbon capture and other
technologies will have to be made
but even with a federal tax incentive
oil companies are making no commitments
yet what we're seeing is that there's no
actual requirement for for companies to
to actually make good on on their net
zero pledges
and so we will need to do some
something else to
to
encourage companies to do that the
canadian association of petroleum
producers says energy prices are
volatile and can't be counted on for
projects that will take decades of
investment or more for that the industry
says it will need more government help
heather your ex-west global news calgary
a significant court ruling in alberta
today alberta's court of appeal ruled
the federal government's environmental
assessment law is unconstitutional
finding it undermines canada's division
of powers and could effectively place
provinces in an economic chokehold by
regulating their natural resources the
impact assessment act formerly known as
bill c-69 allows ottawa to assess how
projects like pipelines will affect the
environment and social issues alberta
premier jason kenney who has dubbed it
the no more pipelines law launched a
legal challenge a majority of five
justices sided with alberta today
calling the act a breathtaking
preemption of provincial authority kenny
is happy though the federal government
said immediately the ruling will be
appealed to the supreme court of canada
this is a huge win for the people of
alberta for their right responsibly to
develop the res their resources the
resources that belong to the people of
this province
the alberta court has made a ruling
today in a four to one split um our view
is the the legislation remains
constitutional and we will be appealing
prime minister justin trudeau says the
law delivered on a promise to reform
what he calls a broken system and
restores public trust in how decisions
on major projects are made the case now
goes to the supreme court but the act
remains in effect in the meantime as
covet 19 drags into its third year the
massive backlog of surgeries that has
been piling up is beginning to decline
that's according to new data hospitals
are working hard to help patients get
the procedures they've been waiting for
for months or even years though as jamie
morocco reports long wait times persist
across the country and health care
workers fear not enough is being done to
get things back to pre-pandemic levels
toronto surgeon dr chef kachevjie was
finally starting to feel confident his
team was catching up on delayed and
cancelled surgeries then came omicron
our backlog got a lot worse again
because we had to slow down the constant
stopping and starting of procedures as
covet 19 caseloads rise and fall coupled
with burnout of healthcare staff and
limited or space forced long delays for
elective surgeries such as cataracts and
joint operations even transplants and
cancer care were set back
close to six hundred thousand fewer
operations were performed across the
country during the first 22 months of
the pandemic compared to 2019 but the
latest data from the canadian institute
for health information reveals wait
times are starting to improve
the challenge going forward though is
we're still being hospitals are still
being hammered by
covered waves our numbers are changing
behind those numbers are real people
suffering marla marshall received her
liver transplant in december after
waiting 11 months you're essentially
just getting sicker and sicker
and
[Applause]
waiting on an organ so that
you can
live jessica bailey first spoke to
global last september and is still
waiting on her kidney transplant the
longer i wait the worse my health gets
bailey's sister says her condition has
deteriorated after testing positive for
covent on sunday we are trying to
preserve the status quo
we are trying to do what we used to do
and and think that we can
solve the problem just throwing money at
the decision ottawa promised two billion
dollars to help with the backlogs but
many provinces say it's not enough
public health experts say the solution
has to come at a hospital level
designating some operating rooms for
emergency use and others for elective
only adding more operating hours and
even distributing surgeries
appropriately between doctors khashoggi
says no matter the plan time is not on
our side
even if we're doing 110 or 115 percent
of the usual run rate you can see it's
going to take us 10 to 20 months
to catch up on on the backlog
jamie morocco global news toronto
an unprecedented move for prince charles
coming up the ceremony the heir to the
throne just performed for the first time
[Music]
in london queen elizabeth was not able
to attend the state opening of
parliament today because of what
buckingham palace calls mobility issues
her son prince charles read the queen's
speech on her behalf
my lords and members of the house of
commons
the heir to the throne formally opened a
new session of parliament and read out
the government's legislative agenda his
son prince william and the imperial
state crown were at his side the queen
has missed the event just twice before
when she was pregnant with sons andrew
and edward in 1959 and 1963.
sri lanka's military has been granted
emergency powers as that country works
to quell deadly anti-government protests
over the island's worst economic crisis
in its history
fighting on the streets has killed at
least seven people this week injured
hundreds of others and a number of homes
and vehicles were torched authorities
can now detain people without warrants
and also search property by force and
shoot looters on site protesters are
calling for the president to resign
misinformation station ahead how
moscow's propaganda has survived on
american airwaves
[Music]
there's a global effort to crack down on
russian state propaganda along with
misinformation and disinformation
because of the invasion of ukraine
vladimir putin continues to make false
claims calling ukrainians nazis and
saying russia is protecting its own
national security and while russia's
state-owned media outlets have largely
been taken off the air in the west one
russian government broadcaster is still
buying its way onto the airwaves in the
u.s
jackson proskow explains
you're listening to radio sports
driving through washington you'll find
the kremlin's message on the dial at
105.5 fm
and we are live from the empire of lies
and we're shacking up the lies in the
empire
that's radio sputnik produced by
russia's state media company from
studios just blocks from the white house
but it's wielding this power but the
power seems to be backfiring
on the united states the russians are
not only winning this thing they're
winning it decisively
as russia's war rages in ukraine sputnik
is selling a very different version of
events one where russia is the victim
this is the first time that it appears
likely that it was the regime in kiev
killing its own citizens who it views as
traitors welcome back to fault lines
critics and the u.s government consider
it pure propaganda
sputnik's hosts claim they're just
questioning the narrative though some
are unapologetically pro-russia part of
what makes sputnik so unusual is that it
has managed to stay on the air as other
russian state broadcasters have either
been banned or ceased broadcasting in
the west
that's because sputnik buys its way onto
the airwaves filings with the u.s
justice department show russia's state
media company spent over half a million
dollars purchasing air time in just the
last six months of 2021. if i felt that
it was all misinformation
we wouldn't be airing it peter chartel
owns kcxl radio near kansas city
missouri he's paid five thousand dollars
per month to air six hours of russian
state programming every day and to say
well you should shut down that
programming
because we don't agree with it
just
is directly opposite of what free speech
is all about the u.s government feels
differently in 2018 it forced sputnik
and the american companies that air it
to register as agents of a foreign
government they must air this disclaimer
on behalf of the federal state unitary
enterprise racial civilian international
information agency moscow russia
russia's war in ukraine prompted the
national association of broadcasters to
go further they've called on stations to
drop all russian programming stations
have so far refused viewers and
listeners who know what they're that
what they're watching
and know that what they're watching is
paid for
can view that content with
a certain degree of skepticism
as the war soldiers on so does sputnik
escaping u.s sanctions and reaching
americans directly
jackson prosko global news washington
worth way beyond a thousand words next
the record-shattering price paid for
this artwork
it's hard to believe there are people
out there with 195 million dollars u.s
to spend on one piece of artwork but an
auction last night in new york city
proves there is andy warhol's silk
screen of marilyn monroe sold for a
record price to an unknown buyer it has
been copied parodied put on t-shirts and
and more so just what makes it worth the
record-breaking price
eric sorenson explains
we come to
the american dream warhol sublime
depiction of marilyn monroe certainly an
auctioneer's dream america's most famous
pop artist and hollywood's most famous
sex symbol 100 million at 110 million
the bidding lasted all of four minutes
170 million
that plus fees and the unknown bidder
will pay 195 million dollars u.s the
highest ever at auction for a 20th
century artwork surpassing picasso's
women of algiers this particular
maryland work by warhol is one of the
most recognizable images
on the planet
it's a contemporary mona lisa warhol was
a gat about on the new york arts scene
but he was a mystery to most people andy
warhol's reticence about himself he
popularized the silk screen technique
creating a distance between the hand of
the artist and the art yes i don't want
to get too close to it his public
persona seemed just as detached his art
a commentary on consumerism and
overexposed celebrity which his silk
screens could mass-produce there's a
certain brilliance in his mobilization
of the technology to comment on his age
but you also think of warhol as the
critic and analyst of the late 20th
century he is the artist who really
dissected fame the image of fame
celebrity culture kiss me
home
marilyn monroe was the perfect symbol of
celebrity culture from this film warhol
used just another publicity photo to
create his most famous artwork and
famous art still seems immune to
economic recession over the last two
years with you know very unpredictable
global times
people have gravitated towards the art
market i think for
culture and beauty and meaning
um but also
a stability in value andy warhol
downplayed his art said it would just be
sold and resold i will look like
everything else i think everything else
should be recycled
like
leftover
food at restaurants he probably didn't
foresee a 200 million dollar recycling
eric sorensen global news toronto
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen tonight's york canada
is the bicycle thief art installation in
downtown halifax we'd love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you